all right hop breath averse
thank you for your patience there we are
back with another hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
our guest today
out of over 300 comics we have
interviewed on here
this is the comic that inspired me to
start my comedy career and he doesn't
like being called
a comedian he likes being called a
storyteller that has humor with a punch
we'll get into that but the first time i
saw
his album 20 stories tall and then his
special 10 stories tall and just
his unique point of view regardless of
what he is you call him a singer a comic
just an overall man of god he is one of
the funniest
minds on the planet and we're so
thrilled to have him here in the hot
breath of hers
let's welcome the one and only mark
lowry everyone let's show him some love
hello joel so good to be with you on
your show we
if they knew how much trouble we had
because i just went live recently and
you got on there and said hey mark i'm
going to talk to you in a few minutes
and i said can we go let's start a
little early and you said yes
because i have physical therapy at two
o'clock
yes come on in everybody have a seat i'm
talking to joel
byer he's a comedian and he tells me
that my stuff inspired him and i'm
honored so we're all
i'm i'm live with you guys he's live
with his people
and then he's also recording this for a
you do a video podcast i have a youtube
channel hot breath comedy network and a
podcast called hot breath
okay yeah you can get that if you want
to
yeah yeah uh so let's go what do you
want to ask me
[Laughter]
so tell me how important i am so we'll
um i know we started early we ended up
starting right when we planned to which
is hilarious
so um yeah we'll uh we'll keep this
rather tight but i would be interested
to ask first off what is it i've in
researching you you don't like to be
called a comedian and you're very
intentional about
not being labeled a comic why is that
well it's because i'm scared
i'm serious when you say here comes a
comedian
uh you better be funny you know and i
honestly got my start with no intention
of ever being funny
i was trying to do something between the
songs
because the lord called me at college i
mean i'm a christian
and therefore i've been labeled a
christian comedian
but i never gave myself that title i
think i'm a storyteller because what i
did i went to these little churches
and i would sing a song and tell a story
sing a song
tell a story and i thought the songs
were the most important thing but what i
come to find out
what people really enjoy the most and
what i
actually enjoy the most probably is
talking and hearing people laugh
and i come from a you know funny family
my brother's a lot funnier than me
at least that's what he tells me and
my dad he's a funny guy and his brothers
oh my gosh you would go to
lowry family reunion and everybody
has two gifts they can all talk and
listen at the same time
because there's ten conversations going
all over that room
and everybody's tuned in to every
conversation
and then we're making comments into
those conversations and
it's a great life for the attention
deficit disordered
person that i am but that's what
resonated i think with your comedy
is and i think you first realized you
were funny when you made your brother's
friends
laugh i believe that's correct and well
they weren't really his friends my
brother did
some modeling in houston and that's
where you get it from
yeah well he was good looking no no no
no i had to be funny or i would not have
been noticed
funny and a mullet let's not forget that
you have yeah i agree
i grew into that years later no when i
was a kid we had
burr haircuts you know what a fur is a
bird
it's just shaved right to the scalp my
dad gave us one
every summer and i loved it i would
still wear it like that except i look
like uncle fester
from the atoms
[Laughter]
so you you you're scared to be called a
comic even though you're proven to be
funny
well i understand people have to label
you
something and that's not the worst thing
but i just think if you say okay ladies
and gentlemen now welcome the funniest
guy and he's so
funny well you better be funny
that's right and i would rather let them
say y'all this guy is going to
bore you into oblivion and then i make
because see let me tell you when i
started out in those independent
fundamental baptist churches
that wouldn't clap because that's giving
glory to men
yeah i see your face they wouldn't shout
because they're afraid someone might
think they're doing it in another
language but they would laugh
and i knew they were listening and all i
cared about is are these people
listening
because you couldn't tell by looking at
them you know
bad independent baptist and back in my
day they were dead or in the door now
now they love jesus and they memorize
those scriptures
but they're don't want they do not want
to be thought of as charismatic
and so they wouldn't they wouldn't
that's giving glory to men if you
applaud you they'd say
amen at the end of a song or something
but they wouldn't
you know i don't know it's all changed
now and it's gotten better have you ever
done comedy clubs or anything
oh lord no oh so you've oh not not even
tried not even curious i tried one time
that was enough
out of my mind well my dad went with me
it was a
guy that i'd met who owned a comedy club
in atlanta when i lived in acworth
oh snap yeah i lived in acworth for a
while
when i joined the vocal band i was
living in acworth georgia
wow yeah so
uh there's i met a guy who owned a
comedy club and he had seen me and he
thought
i could do it he said you got all these
faces and you got the you know you can
do this
and he talked me into it and uh i never
did it again
but what happened let's get into this
well i think they laughed
but it wasn't the kind of laughter i was
used to i don't know what was different
about it
you know first of all my crowd is
usually sober
yes you know and i'm not i'm not
counting for all of them but most of
them
and hey i'm kidding about that i mean
and and and i know where they're coming
from i know how they
think i'm one of them i was raised with
them
i don't want to leave them i don't want
to go
do i did an interview for people
magazine they said you want to cross
over and i said yes
if i can take the crossover but i don't
want to go without him
uh-huh and i just i have no desire to do
that i've never had
it's not my calling and i thank god for
people like you and others
jeff foxworthy that loves the lord and
he is
hauling the water to the desert well i'm
fine with singing for the choir
see have you ever bombed on stage then
do you ever have an experience like that
yeah with bill one time i was you know
with bill gaither what was so
glorious about the humor that we
created really because when i joined him
i had never done anything but monologues
i'd never had another person on stage
with me so i would do a monologue and he
would interrupt me
from the piano bench and then i'd turn
around and sass him and that led to this
and that the other
and after a few nights of me sassing him
we got rid of the monologues that i was
doing
that that just stayed in my solo shows
and he and i created this
he's the old man and i was the perpetual
10 year old
you know jumping around making fun of
his hair they always kept my mic
on because you could not if my mic
wasn't hot
the joke was over by the time they
turned it up you know that
timing timing so bob
my bill bob bob told them
to keep my mic hot so they did and which
i loved of course and some things worked
some didn't
one night something i said didn't work
that popped in my head and
it was crickets
and bill said well that one
that didn't go yeah on stage he's you
know he said whoo i said well i'll just
save that for when i go secular
right oh my gosh
the audience didn't care because they
knew you know
i had no ever i mean if they knew me
they know i don't care about going
second
we had 20 000 people the night i said
that on stage
very few secular shows have 20 000
people
that's what that's when gaither was at
the height of the vocal band i mean we
were soaring
howard and vestal were alive that big
homecoming tour was on the road it was
huge
and bill caught me an intermission and
said you're gonna go apologize to that
crowd
i said why he said because you said
that's for when you go secular
and i'm going is this man lost his mind
surely he knows
they know i'm kidding i guess
and i said i'm not doing it he said oh
oh yeah you i said
i read my lips i'm not apologizing
for saying that and so i then i thought
about it
and and then i got up there that
afterwards i want to let him force me to
do anything
you know i'm not going to apologize for
anything i've ever said unless
i feel like it you know that's a lie
if you're apologizing because someone
twisted your arm you're not
sorry but i thought it over
and i got upset listen y'all bill shoot
me out at intermission told me i have to
apologize to y'all because
i said that joke was for when i go
secular you know the one that bombed
and i said let me just tell you this we
have 20
000 people here tonight where am i gonna
go
if i want a bigger crowd where am i
gonna go seriously
and i'm not called to go secular
i thank god for those people who are you
know i'm not
called to be a plumber either but i
thank god for those people who are
you know i'm not called to be a doctor
but i thank god for dr michael greaser
who fixed my foot
i was gonna say you're not called to
ride any scooters again as well
ever we learned that after breaking your
leg twice doing that oh
yeah yeah i broke my broke my leg twice
on that same road yeah this has gotten
too serious hadn't this supposed to be
funny
no this is this is like the the inside
the actor's studio for comedians we
we show like the stories behind the
comics so you're you're in good company
so well how many you got live on your on
your i got 1500 how many you got
[Laughter]
why you gotta do me like that mark
oh because you're a puppy and you
deserve to have fewer numbers
we got 18 strong over here good i'm glad
you know what they matter i was going to
say they do but then when you
threw out your number like how many do
you have by the way i you know that you
know that we know that i have more
just so you know just so you don't think
i'm like
i do you're on i mean every day you have
hundreds of people on your live streams
but that's
it's aspirational you've raised you know
what isn't it fun
too it is fun enjoy it yeah it is
19 now not to brag 19 yeah now
especially during a pandemic i love
checking in on these people
first of all they now we got 1600 they
wouldn't be following me
if they didn't you know
like me checking in on them i like
checking in on them and see what you
don't understand we don't do a lot of
humor on that check-in you watch it
i sing we sing out of these old hymnals
that i got my
laptop jacked up on because we couldn't
connect them but i hate those
when they when they have the laptop like
this you know on those shows and
all you see is the most hideous part of
the human body
all of this right here singing out of
their chin yeah
oh you've got to get it above the jeans
you know yeah i need to get better at
singing i want to
incorporate that let me uh i heard you
now listen i heard you a little bit
and i just let that go
what about joseph did you know
maybe a remix hey it's kind of elvis
vibrato you got going there
oh so i can sing yo jeff
[Music]
you know what i'm working on joseph did
you know uh what did i say mary did you
know joseph did you know and
jesus we know you knew uh-huh you're
working are you are you being serious
i didn't know if you had a remix up your
sleeve maybe a hip-hop remix
no did you know there is a disco version
of mary did you know
i did not know mary didn't know that
either it's incredible
it's it's by a lady named christine w
and she enunciates every word
and it's a mary did you marry
i mean it's a disco and it played in
disco
bars all over the world one christmas
and i didn't have to leave the house and
i told everybody in those bars what i
think about jesus
now is that not cool that's powerful
yeah and i never had to leave the house
you never feel you you've got yeah
you're you're you're good
you've got residuals on residuals you
don't have to leave the house ever
if you don't want to well i love it it's
well deserved though oh we're down to
1400 get more entertaining
well we're up to 20 so not to brag
[Laughter]
we're up to 22 now so when people let me
ask you this since you're interviewing
me and i'm in
so if people want to come see you do
your comedy which i told you if you ever
get to houston you need to let me know
i will for sure but they can go to where
to find out more about you
my website is joelbyerscomedy.com i have
a comedy special on there called the
trophy husband
and i have more info about my podcast
and when i'll be back on the road and
things like that
hey but i'm a 10 been doing comedy
almost 11 years now
and uh mark's the whole reason for the
season
unbelievable so did i put that where
they could see you i mean
how do you what was so cool in looking
back at your
your uh stand up or your storytelling to
prepare for this was like
your ability to incorporate physicality
into your
performance how do you how do you tell a
story
like verbally but then add that like
fourth dimension of the
characterization of it well can you give
me an example of what street
i don't know you mean my face yeah like
your facial expressions are incredible
well let me tell you a story about that
i vide metzger
of the kansas city youth for christ she
and her husband
she just passed away godly wonderful
lady
and they would they had a channel 50 was
the station in kansas city it was a
christian tv
it was the first time i was ever
videotaped from beginning to end of one
of my shows right
or the young people at the kansas city
youth for christ
which was probably 1981
somewhere back i graduated from college
in 80 and by 1981 8283 somewhere in
there
i was going to kansas city youth for
christ once a year well
they videotaped one of my performances
and let me tell you joel byers it was
the first time
mark lowry had ever seen his faces
now i used to make faces in the mirror
when i was a kid
just because we didn't have iphones yet
you know we were limited with what we
could do to entertain ourselves
and i would my belts i'd get in the
mirror
and make all these faces and i would die
laughing right yeah that's the one
yeah and then uh like that or that
can go either way wow so
then and my mother's very expressive her
face was you know she'd get mad her
eyebrows would shoot to the back of her
skull
you know and so i went with
at first let me just be honest with you
the night
i i remember it like it was yesterday i
slayed
they had like a an office area to kansas
city
for christ and they had a tv on a on a
stand that was back in the days when tvs
were huge you know
you know not huge like they are now but
you know heavy
so sitting on a stand i was lying on the
lane lying i was prostrating
across straight on the floor and i think
i got that one right
and uh
yeah and i saw
my faces for the first time ever
and i almost quit the i mean i've had so
many
quitting periods really into my life
and calling first of all the lord didn't
tell me he was going to turn into comedy
he called me to sing
[Music]
but i noticed you know like i said they
they look bored when i sing but boy
they'd sit on the edge of their seat
when i started telling my tails
yeah and i thought well man i better
dance with who brought me
so i think the lord was sneaky
he did not let me know if he just said
mark i want you to go into comedy i'd
have found myself in the belly of a
whale
if you know what i'm saying jonah and
the whale member
oh i'm listening to you he called the
prophet and the prophet ran
because well you know i mean oh lord
have you
told me because that's scary to me
and if you're not a little bit scared
you're kind of simple
to get up and think you can make a room
full of people laugh
yeah don't aren't you a little nervous
those butterflies
i mean it's a good feeling now it's like
oh that feels it's like ooh that gives
me energy i'm ready to go
for sure but in the early days it was
like oh my goodness what am i
what yep and then some days it's up
other days it's down
and you're like yeah i'm gonna be the
next big comic and then the next day
you're like
oh i'm quitting comedy and going back to
enterprise rent-a-car
i can't do this but the difference is
you
wanted to be a comedian right yes
yeah always always and then i decided to
do it senior year of college
the first time i actually tried it but i
wanted to be a comedian my whole life
after hearing
seriously 20 stories tall and you
bringing your real life experiences
to the stage and being so vivid about it
and my mom my mom said that you um
you reminded her uh so much of me
and like our adhd and our experiences
with teachers
and um we're about to we're gonna we're
gonna wrap this up here
in a minute here just so you can get to
your physical therapy but i want to
bring on a special guest
because this is the person responsible
for us even being here
today oh really yes you must be your
mother
yeah it is let's give it up for
mama joel in here mama
mama joel in here hey
hey mark hi oh hold on i gotta get my
screen i'm on the screen
there we go wait i don't see her oh
she's uh she's on the zoom
okay then i got to get up in the corner
to see her okay go ahead yeah mama
hey mark hey mom look at us
hey we're doing it
yeah thanks for joining us so nice to
meet you you seem to have a very nice
son
i do i do yeah do you like his comedy
i do i do does he ever embarrass you
um sometimes well yeah he better
territory
well you know my mom she had a lot of
kids come up to her and say
are you really a screamer and she said
well that's the way he heard it
[Laughter]
yeah they were there was a lot of
commonalities in your stories
and uh when joel's sisters heard the
stories on 20 stories tall
they they said that's joel that's joel
now i do have one question about your
mama
did she really witness to the obscene
phone callers
oh no it wasn't obvious yeah one yeah
she would
yeah definitely but the madeleine murray
o'hare one
oh my god it's the one i remember most
specifically oh yeah but she would
oh she lived for an opposing phone call
but we didn't get many
you know yeah once you tell them about
jesus they usually lose your number
but she's planting those seeds oh yeah
she witnessed that the kroger lady she
went
i got my hair cut one time and she had
that barber on his knees before we left
and
[Laughter]
oh that's all this is this is history
right here mark i've never brought my
mom on the show before but i had to for
you
i'm sorry i love that your mom
called you hyper creative
because i always thought of joel as
tigger and did not want to temper that
because he wasn't being tigger all over
the place on everybody's nerves
he just wasn't you know he wasn't being
joel
but i loved your stories about miss
holland i'm a retired teacher
um and she just recently she just
recently passed away
oh my gosh joel had a teacher in the
third grade miss free degree or i've
tried to find her
she saw and joel what other teachers
didn't appreciate
so she he was great he did have some
really good teachers who did appreciate
appreciate his sense of humor and
imagination his hyper creativity
exactly exactly well i'm fixing to take
this broken foot
thank you mother thank you for hanging
out mike hey mama thank you
you're young enough to be my daughter i
can tell so i just call you by
the first name linda god bless you yes
mark call me actually you're only about
two weeks older than i
am oh is that right well joel you can
call me mr lowry from now on
yes sir mr lowry thank you so much for
your time is there anything you want to
promote or anything
oh tonight shonda pierce and i are gonna
be uh
together on her little uh show she she's
charging tickets
and this is the second time she's done
it it's me ken davis
and shonda and i don't know what we're
gonna do but probably
won't be half as entertaining as this
was all right
well thank you mark lowry thanks for uh
making me a comedian
all right joel god bless you buddy god
bless you thank you
you